that's right officer getting special
attention as government leaders work to
overhaul the US tax code one u.s.
senator is concerned about people that
are using alpacas that's right alpacas
it gets tax breaks as a whole tax
write-off skocy US Treasury about 1.2
trillion dollars in 2015 and that's
comparable to the all discretionary
spending approved by Congress tonita
copal explains how some people think
alpacas are part of the problem Tony
good morning good morning alpacas are
prized for their soft fur funky
hairstyles and gentle demeanor but
Arizona Senator Jeff Flake says the real
allure for many owners is that hefty tax
break Teddy come here at Alma Park
alpacas Rose mow gurmann tens a herd of
56 animals that's burlap burlap Gaston
Gaston Adriana Adriana using their fur
to stalk her yarn shop everything here
is from your animals yes
but back in the early 2000 she was a
private IT consultant with 200 acres of
unused farmland and a hefty tax bill
were you looking for a tax break or were
you looking to own alpacas well I think
it was a combination of both I wanted to
do something useful with my property and
I do love animals but yes
in the beginning I was like this is a
great opportunity she bought 13 alpacas
deducted the entire 50 thousand plus
sales price from her income taxes and
instantly dropped her state property
taxes from eighteen thousand a year to
one thousand seventeen thousand dollars
I hear because you put out pakka's on
the property yes that's very good yes I
could tell you for a fact that when I
got into it I think there were people
that simply got into it for that a
cousin of llamas and native to Peru
alpacas arrived in America in the 1980s
under the current tax code they are
considered livestock like sheep or
cattle that makes their purchase price
and maintenance tax deductible some tax
breaks are simply a drain on the
Treasury and I would put this in the
category yes
Arizona Senator Jeff Flake calls it the
alpaca tax fleece in a new report tax
rackets outlandish loopholes to lower
tax liabilities he argues that the
government should stop supporting what
he considers exotic pets I'm not trying
to tell them don't
I'll pack us but I am saying that we
have to right-size in our tax code so in
your view the packing industry is not a
legitimate successful industry well it's
not like livestock
there's no legitimate market we are a
livestock industry just like the sheep
industry we shear our animals once a
year we turn that into marketable
products and clothing and things for end
users but sign horse is executive
director of the alpaca owners
association while he admits that alpaca
fiber is not yet mainstream he says
alpaca farmers deserve the same support
as other small business owners I don't
talk to a lot of our owners that say I
got into this because I needed a tax
break Rose motormen says her alpaca
business doesn't need any tax help here
does still she hopes senator flake
considers for the sake of other alpaca
owners do I think that they're pets no
do I love them all yes but they're not
in my basement they're not in my living
room they're in a barn their livestock
senator flakes report details as much as
fifty billion dollars in tax breaks
including deductions for gamblers and
golf course owners but alpaca owners
have been among the most vocal in
response the senator says he's getting
alpaca pictures mailers and a very nice
Teesha good that's right I mean that one
person's tax break is another person's
tax giveaway absolutely so that's why
it's hard to do tax from Tony thank you
so much did you see thing